بحكم موقعه في الجبال يعد مسجد تيمم
الاكثر المباني تضررا من زلزال المغرب
نحن هنا في قلب قريه تيربل باقليم الحوز
حيث واحد من اهم المواقع التاريخيه في
جبال الاطلس الكبير
مسجد تين ميل يعتبر تراثا فريدا ومثالا
متميزا للعماره الموحديه هذا ما تبقى من
مسجد تيم التاريخي الذي تاثر بدوره
بالزلزال العنيف الذي ضرب المغرب بني
المسجد عام
1248 خلال حقبه الخليفه الموحدي عبد
المؤمن بن علي وتميز ببعده الروحي
والحضاري المسجد الذي بني في القرن الثاني
عشر من قبل الموحدين ظل صامدا تسع قرون
مقاوما جميع الظروف لكنه لم يصمد امام
الطبيعه التي دمرت اجزاء منه
[موسيقى]
من هذا المسجد كانت تنطلق قوه الموحدين
نحو الاندلس للدفاع عن مدنه كما ان له
اسهامه كثيره تظل راسخه في وجدان الناس
يقصد المسجد التاريخي كثير من باحثي
الاثار والحضاره اضافه الى سياح مهتمين
بالسياحه الثقافيه
مسجد من يقع على بعد 100 كم من مراكش على
الطريق المؤدي الى اسيا يعتبر جوهره
معماريه حقيقيه هذا المبنى الموحد دون
قائم كبير وعمارته نموذجيه لهذا العصر بعد
الدراسات تشير الى ان المسجد شيد تخليدا
لذكرى الزعيم الروحي للموحدين المهدي بنت
ومرت المدفون في موقعه منه
وبعد كارثه الزلزال تحول المعلم المتميز
في تاريخ العماره الاسلاميه الى اطلال
مدمره تؤلم ذاكره السكان
[موسيقى]
كثيرون عبروا عن حسرتهم امام مشهد هذا
المعلم التاريخي الذي يعد في مركز النسيج
السكاني والعمراني للمنطقه
[موسيقى]